hey everybody Sebastian Maniscalco I'm
doing a thing here for Fandango sounds
like something you'd say in Italian if
you got good news your sister had a baby
that's Fandango anyway they're asking me
to welcome you to the summer movie
season
the reason they asked me to do this is
because I have a new movie about my
father playing this summer it's an
hilarious story about my relationship
with my family and especially my father
starring me and Robert De Niro as my dad
so this summer you got a lot of options
but all of them are hot so getting a
nice air-conditioned theater and watch
about my father family isn't one
important thing it's everything I can't
believe you put this all together from
what we have in the kitchen it's
artichoke and pulse
[Music]
a little bit